he's a violinist is a freestyle rapper
and we took to the streets of Los
Angeles to serenade people from the
comfort of their homes to help them get
through lockdown six feet six feet boom
nailing this we are going around and
serenading people I'm gonna ask a few
things and then I'm also gonna rap about
that dog because it is spectacular what
are your names
Oksana Pasha and Colin Thank You Colin
but you know just keeping it right down
on the boring name what was your
profession before all this happens Colin
what do you do how am i doing so we're
gonna serenade you
whichever song you want to do basically
I'm happy with yeah let's do it
[Music]
I hope the police have come I guess
that's what happens when you spit sick
fire there's people in the parts yeah so
we're gonna freestyle for you guys
Oksana Pasha Colin steal the husky model
coach photographer fashion stylist
[Music]
we start things off talking to Oksana a
model citizen say a real charmer if
you've got a problem just waddle in to a
roughish she'll teach you how to model
in doesn't matter if your nose is croc
or if your is being pulled off by a
massive butchers hook she can say
beauty's inside all of the poses she
provides from the side maybe pop your
hip put your chin in that is basically
how you do the model in and then behind
her right to the back there he'll take
the photos name is Pasha so passionate
about developing film he's like gonna
heat it up in the darkroom not kiln
otherwise you burn it put it on the big
screen then : a man who's so keen to
make sure everybody looking fly wearing
a tank top a real rib guy who wearing
nice sweats are really really jealous
but then the main one man's best friend
is I see him the face reveal he a husky
and you know his name is steel he's so
enthusiastic he goes the whole hog he
will chase you down cuz he's a vicious
dog I'm sure he's really friend or
wouldn't bark at me I could take him on
the leaf to the park for me he'd be
running over there and see him back down
saying Kristoff your rock shut it up
right now
[Music]
thank you for watching the video if
you're enjoying it so far please do like
and subscribe more rats coming up now we
use a people shouting anal and butter
okay if you want to give you it like
four or five suggestions and then we'll
do you like Voltaire you're a French boy
aren't you so yeah sorry Pierre French
man with an arrogant air trying to
correct my pronunciation when I'm saying
Voltaire oh let me issue an apology I
didn't know about French philosophy I
think therefore I am besides Descartes
you think you're very clever think
you're very smart
but that's okay it's not my fault
they're never whole never falter when
it's Balt I need some weed in there so I
go to the Rocky Mountains Colorado you
know the best day abbreviate to see oh
if you're loving that 4:20 time just go
right there better than CA I allow
switch that all for the a that's a vowel
when you're up there I would never try
fall you could visit Gunderson Crested
view or rifle all three cities when you
go there obviously Mile High City called
Denver are you from there yeah you know
me I'm from Colorado but now I love Kobe
reppin him when I'm over here although
your shirt says paces gotta make it up
yeah you know I never planned ever
assume the Pacers are coming from
Indiana but Kobe's on your shirt I
really got a hand yeah best player yet I
call him amber sadly he passed away we
say r.i.p Kobe today and then I move on
yeah I'm up to snuff I always use that
Lube when I do butt stuff I never ever
want to go in dry I don't advise if you
want to a nor try you got to do it
it is not beginner sport you've got to
do it properly like how you were taught
always get consent never even lingam
always train an easier way in with a
finger if there's bacteria if there's a
virus just spray it on it
yeah it'll Ides us it alludes it moves
away you need lifestyle the amount I'm
spitting today admittedly my saliva
could not you reach because you're at a
safe distance about 24 feet
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yeah other places from Indiana in
fat right yes
British boy got basketball right thank
you very much for watching make sure you
like comment subscribe and also make
sure you check out our mando violin
comedy for the only violin stand-up
comedian in the world that has a fly and
it is annoying
[Music]